Boston has no great heritage for not
only technology but specifically for
technology related to kind of business
to business and infrastructure
stackdriver was founded in Boston
Massachusetts we founded the company in
2012 it's been really exciting to watch
stackdriver grow and evolve now
deploying stackdriver
across Google infrastructure and taking
advantage of all these exciting Google
technologies
it was beyond anything that we could
have expected only two years
hi I'm Dan Belcher I'm the lead product
manager for operations on the Google
cloud team prior I was one of the
founders of stackdriver
when we started stackdriver we really
didn't have a specific product in mind
instead we were really interested in the
growth of the public cloud and what we
did is we reached out to hundreds of
customers that were running applications
in the cloud and asked them what their
pain points were what we found is that a
lot of customers had disparate tools for
monitoring the cloud platform their
systems their application uptime and so
forth and it was really difficult for
them to not only manage those systems
but to look across those systems to you
know identify it and troubleshoot those
issues and so when we built stackdriver
we built one service that brought all
those capabilities you know together
stack drivers of performance and
availability monitoring for public cloud
infrastructure so you connect us to your
cloud infrastructure either on Amazon
Web Services or Google cloud platform
and we'll show you everything that's
happening inside your infrastructure we
take on the burden of helping you
visualize and run your application
successfully on the cloud without
stackdriver you've got a set up all
kinds of different tooling logging
monitoring dashboarding and we make it
really powerful and simple and really
easy to get started I think that that
removes a lot of excitement when it
comes to reducing a number of
applications one needs to manage our
system so being able to bring that in
one place has alleviates a lot of
problems for DevOps able to see how the
entire episode turns performing
health-wise and performance we also
provide some great tools that are
industry-leading in terms of being able
to do multi conditional learning so now
that you have all the signals come into
one place you can then tailor alerts to
be very specific to conditions that
you're monitoring or relate to an
incident that you've received in the
past
I think custom metrics are one of the
most interesting parts of stackdriver
as an application developer you know
which metrics are the best indicators of
system health so you don't want to
necessarily wait for system metrics like
CPU or memory usage to rise before you
learn the problem so using custom
metrics you can monitor things that are
specific to your application that gives
you an even earlier indication of a
problem they allow you to react more
quickly because you know which metrics
are important in your system we're also
very excited about some of the advanced
features like anomaly detection and
insights that will bring to this product
so people can actually get proactive
insights from the product rather than
just manually setting up alerts and
looking at incidents I primarily focus
on our logging product and our logging
product really is a tool that we have
built that works at scale and can look
at like large enterprise scale customers
who are sending us like gigabytes per
second scale of logs we give them a
platform to visualize those logs and we
also work with those customers to give
them more analytics capabilities on top
of the data so they can make IP ops
operational business analytical as well
as security related decisions find them
quickly and take action monitoring
alerting incident management logging
together into one place
what start driverís promises is that it
will make it easier more streamlined and
faster to find and fix issue stackdriver
has always been about making operations
easier for many people writing
applications in the cloud stack driver
will be the only tool that you need for
monitoring and logging you'll have one
interface one place to go to help you
identify troubleshoot and resolve issues
Google acquired stack driver because we
share a vision around you know creating
insight out of all this data that were
very
together and so it's good to be among a
larger group that believes in the same
things